and then without my permission there's
poop and there's my body repellent
I'm Elizabeth south I'm a private
investigator here in Los Angeles
California my name is John I'm a PI here
in Los Angeles I've been doing it for
about two and a half years I've been
doing this for about five or six years
and I have experience from surveillances
to background checks to ask that
searches to dealing with custody cases I
do background checks asset checks
service of process surveillance scene
investigation witness interviews witness
statements we're about to play two
truths and a lie
regarding embarrassing highschool
stories which as we know high school is
one big embarrassing story let's see
which one of our subjects was voted most
dishonest hi I'm Rachel and one time in
high school I fainted on the bus and
pissed myself hi my name is a Manny and
one time when I was 16 I pooped my pants
on a neighborhood walk hi my name is
Jake and I got punched in the face over
a muffin all right we've got peed I was
really hoping Jake was gonna all right
so give us a little more narrative about
this muffin incident so I went to a very
small school Christian in the middle of
one of our mass days so I went to get a
snack you know a little snack shack and
I was confirming bought him off and kids
behind me broke out in a fight bump me
into the kid in front of me who dropped
him up and he turned and punch me in the
face talk to me about this snack shack
it went sounds like a big fat lie and
just in the main hallway there was like
a little shack of some sort that they
would set up on chapel days and they
would sell goods they bought from Costco
Costco
it's just Kirkland brand products he
says Costco that why are you throwing
that detail in there it is what they
sold so it wasn't even a good muffin the
crap Costco cinnamon swirl generic offer
okay all right they make good muffin
maybe Costco makes me do you make good
luck they're good enough to get punched
over the one guy punched you what it was
on accident
no I'm purpose he was mad that I made
him drop stuff was it the last muffin
okay just bumped him why because he was
upset was he a pro muffin guns and
irrational
you never told your parents I told my
parents lady care okay I was fine I was
is a very durable child general I've
never heard anyone describe himself as a
very dirt that's a great description
interesting so you just took one when
then I took two he punched you twice
yeah like in direct center oh my god and
then what you stood there and looked at
each other apologized immediately after
because he realized what he had done and
I didn't want to escalate it so he was
kind of blinded by muffin rage you
didn't want to escalate after you got
punched between the eyes twice it's the
Christian thing to do
that's true yeah so your story was that
you pooped your pants on a walk in your
neighborhood I was like sixteen I only
ever had a few minutes notice before I
had to go number two normally that
happens when the team does diet pills
this was just like bell peppers way far
from my home and I don't want to knock
on someone's door and be like why did we
just go behind a tree it's Arizona trees
don't exist there that's right I need to
understand the geography here fake trees
don't exist either squat behind a little
cactus or rock or a Rob there are trees
even in the neighborhoods the kind you
[ __ ]
I tried calling my friends be like you
got picking me up yo can you poop for me
no can you drag I need a Wi-Fi okay no
answer and then without my permission is
poop and there's like my body rebelled
and visibly like got to my pants was it
like kind of the runny kind sorry I get
it no I need to know this it didn't have
enough cohesion to just sit nicely like
a little like stone and my pants it was
like I'm gonna come down or gravity
takes me it was not a concise turning
but it was enough of an item that it's
sort of tumbled out so it was a very
traumatic experience what I did was I
made a little tourniquet with my shorts
so some of the poop fell out flatter a
splatter I had to use this curse I got
from my grandma from Egypt to mop it up
as I walked home and that was the real
casualty yeah Oh Egyptian grandma poop
purse I'm just writing this down
[Music]
Jake are you doing okay
somebody can't really keep it together
we got a lot of intimate details Rachel
you want to walk us through the
narrative of this yes so I think I was
in my junior year of high school and I
was walking to the bus and I knew that
my sugar was like a little low because I
was actually taking diet pills but I
fainted it I didn't know what happened
so the next thing I knew when I woke up
was I was sitting in a the bus seat and
in my neighbor's sitting next me and
he's touching my arm and I realized that
my pants were wet he like whispered to
me and fainted and pissed herself once
we got to school everybody got off and
then he kind of like he walks like
shielding me kind of and then I went
into school and had to change and so
like my gym pants know what time of year
was a so junior my mom had passed away
so and she passed away in October I
think this might happen like six months
after so probably like May I was
thinking it's really cold there I know
Stacy little in East Coast oh yeah
winter and you're doing that that's
gonna be miserable
didn't anybody else in school ever know
or like you just oh yeah and then I
remember like somebody came up to me and
like I'd called me like a xanax [ __ ]
that's hard I never had like somebody
say something like that to me little
Missy pissy pants maybe I was not that
was my senior nickname little Missy
Missy pants okay see I have this
intuition Ellie yeah he probably looked
me up now I'm just getting yeah keep
that in mind
was there high school Tottenville sounds
big you changing your gym clothes yeah I
think I left them in my locker just
because of like the drama of it all when
I had gym like two periods later like I
just threw them in the garbage and I
just wore my gym clothes home I mean of
pay like seventy bucks for a pair of
pants for a high school it's hard to
throw those away okay so if I can be
totally honest after my mom passed away
a few my aunt's like took me shopping
and like that was basically some of the
things that they had bought so like yes
should I have not thrown them out but I
did oh my god this huh
do you faint routinely I've fainted in
my wife probably like five times
yeah and that was not the first time
yeah was not the first time I think I've
been to like one other time a little bit
earlier like six months before kind of
like around when my mom had passed but
then like since then I fainted like at
least two more times
some good Liars in here all right when
you're in school again was this with the
muffin incident I was a freshman okay
what was the most impactful thing about
that day I remember feeling astonished
like what just happened and then I kind
of went by in a very fast and now back
to your story what time of year was this
uh like calendar year I was a junior is
warm out spring how old were you
oh it was before my 17th birthday I was
16 it was like April 4 my 17th birthday
my friends got me Hershey's chocolate in
adult diapers I have to get back to the
consistency of the fecal deposit do you
yeah there's no car what color wasn't no
weird color color was it
Wow shape shape nope it was a it was a
bell shape I'm pretty sure it would be
green I feel like you described this in
contradictory terms I feel like it has
changed a little bit actually it started
out as you said something about I said
splatter before that you said something
fell out of your shorts yeah but she was
saying that it came out you know down
her leg and everything yeah when was she
holding in exactly my question sludgy
okay see that clarifies thing sort of a
lentil soupy type of we have some things
of concerns right here obviously the
consistency of the bowel movement this
guy we don't have a Lemmy he's hasn't
given a lot of detail he's not been
forthcoming with detail he's holding
back a lot he's only given exactly what
you asked for and your responsive being
hit in the middle of the head twice and
being like okay that's okay and then
over here we know that she's an
incredible liar we just saw her do the
whole yeah miss pissy pants thing in the
same way sarcasm now she's getting too
far lying yeah what's your knee jerk
reaction so I'm leaning towards this
girl right here in the middle the story
kind of changed and then the way she
described and I mean she would have to
have big balls to come on you know
BuzzFeed and talk about I poked myself
and here's what it was liking it was
sludgy
Hollywood do that why would you even go
into that sort of dude a story with the
diapers and Hershey's kiss was a really
good touch two poops probably the most
embarrassing thing yeah I've been
working now Jake now I'm second-guessing
myself I thought at the very beginning
in his single line introduction
he mentioned he was sixteen years older
huh in fact I wrote that down because he
said his age and he didn't actually
specify that this happened in high
school twice since then he said another
time I was 14 or 15 and they said I was
in freshman year he didn't give a lot of
details so there's not a lot of room for
mistake yeah he's been trying not to
laugh the entire time we were here with
a poop story he keeps looking at me and
the poop story he's outrageous enough to
you can tell you like they're ever gonna
believe this is true and Rachel's
looking at me like I'm this process is
just so interesting your API it's not
what your some know what you think about
sorry well this is tough you all deserve
some credit for making us work and think
very hard he just keeps the last better
my vote is for Jake I think Jake's I'm
you know I'm kind of touring I'll go
with Jake to you on this one now who in
fact told the lie I'm so pumped this was
so excited I feel bad about you I know I
like in this phase in my life where
underwear was just too uncomfortable for
me so I didn't even have that like extra
security you know the runners shorts
[Music]